[Music]
sometimes when i'm in la for long enough
if i'm living in la i find myself
getting really into like cliche
stereotypical la things like um
fads you know like nutrition fads i got
into
smoothie and i'll just find myself
casually mentioning these
activities to people who don't live in
la and um i i sometimes get judged for
it and one such occasion was um
when christian and i got
not to rope you into this but we got
really into spinning spin class we would
go we were spinners we yeah we were
hardcore so to speak
well
two people will laugh at that joke um
you i i think you're the one that got
into it first you don't both have to be
into spitting our friends around the
same time our friend kira o'donnell
shout out yes got us both into it maybe
i was first but uh we would go with him
the three of us would go spinning in
silver lake in a very hip
hip neighborhood in l.a uh he got you
into it yeah y-a-s yeah now of course
yeah yeah queen it was before yaz queen
became the queen yeah
oh well before yeah
thankfully because we would have said it
constantly it's closed down yeah a
couple years ago
we used to go spinning
at ya's and we would do it so you know
it's for those of you who've done it you
know how physically demanding it is but
um everyone else in the class
mostly women i would say
um
by the end of the class seemed you know
like they had had a good workout but we
were
not here christian and myself were just
destroyed and we were drenched in sweat
and i i remember beat red we looked
horrible we looked very close to passing
like dying and everyone else i remember
at the end of class they collect their
things and it was a time where people
seem to be socializing like um hey good
to see you you know i could hear little
pockets of socializing and every once in
a while i know somebody in the class
because it was in
an area where a lot of actors lived and
i remember catherine hahn being there
occasionally and like trying to and
she's so friendly and easy to talk to
but i um i i i literally i couldn't put
a sentence together i remember her being
like she must think i'm
i i don't know what she thinks of me
because the only times i'd run into her
were when i was like
we were out of shape it's fair to say
and now we've become
ripped oh we're we're like we have
incredible physiques and we have
incredible health
so it's a happy ending katherine
wouldn't recognize me no you're a
totally different person then by the way
we should get on the show that'd be
great life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i'm
your unrecognizably ripped host justin
long life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my equally
we've been going to the gym a lot you're
like your generation's billy blanks yeah
wait he was he the tybo guy yeah yeah
the typo what yes i took me a second wow
started
started a reference shame because billy
blank sounds like such a it sounds like
a gangster from the like badge barely
blank say it sounds
generations uh maybe
because he he became ubiquitous
at a very specific time maybe i just
missed that maybe um you know i i just
missed sometimes like i'm close to
people who like would reference rugrats
or clarissa like pokemon pokemon pokemon
yeah or um beanie babies oh i missed
speedy but now we're missing everything
you know i'll turn on the tv and it's
like
at some big awards show and it's like
with presenters
uh divan suado and
and
malcolm and jakindy divon suado is a
really funny fake huge celebrity name
and i'm like i no idea and then of
course you quickly learn
you know who people are if you've
watched it because then if i fall down
instagram long enough yes if i'm not
working long enough during my like non
work because when i am working i'm i can
be a bit of a workaholic oh
whoa double tie-in yeah double times now
let me ask you why are we
why are we talking about workaholics and
running
or biking but we were talking about
biking which is exercise yes and people
bike in marathons don't they maybe they
don't call marathons
well let's stick with the workaholics
okay well i'll tell you why i'll answer
your rhetorical question for you
our because our guest today
was the star of a movie called a hit
movie a sundance darling oh it was a it
was a real darling britney runs a
marathon
as well as a cast member of the hit show
workaholics
that was a nice oh what a tie-in double
tie-in our guest today is
jillian bell the hilarious jillian bell
oh man she's so funny and she's so good
i i remember seeing her at the
groundlings years ago
she was so good that it really stood out
i'll never forget certain we talk about
some of these sketches uh that were in
my limited memory banks but she was one
of those performers that struck me
because she was so committed to what she
was doing and and didn't seem to be
looking for the joke which had has
become a pretty common thing to see now
i think in comedy you see people trying
to be funny i feel like that's the theme
that keeps coming out of the show yeah
yeah it's a thing that we really respond
to and
hopefully other people do like yeah yeah
we really like it and she's a good
example of it yeah there's a
truthfulness in what she does and um and
if you've seen any of her work like she
was on great episode of kirby enthusiasm
where she plays uh a brave performance
too where she plays a girl who a woman
who exposes her midriff uh midriff why
did i want to say mid-drift no it's
midriff that was always tricky for me
too midriff
um confused
how to pronounce midriff i know it's
tokyo drift
um
it's no drift but she she is um yeah you
see she's been stealing scenes for 22
jump street it's seen stealing scenes
feelings very funny people friend of the
not aggressively stealing no no not not
also not doing robbing them no not doing
it uh with any ill intent no just really
committed and funny and um and
i i just one of my my favorite like
younger comedic performers so uh if you
don't know oh she's like an old man
right now i know but she is younger and
she is younger um and
she's
we were talking about marathons because
she's also you oh you mentioned that um
oh what else uh and she's
[Laughter]
what else is she in she said a lot she's
done a lot she's not always she's great
julian bell um i hadn't talked to her in
a while but um we had been
talking about doing this for a long time
so i'm so glad it finally happened and
i'm glad for you guys because you're
gonna get to hear it let's do it all
right here she is the very funny and and
sweet really sweet person julian bell
life could be a dream
hello hello again boom and nobody will
meet again
[Music]
i just got the wildest text from my
mother oh god
wait what text did you just get well she
she is
very uh how do i say this without being
offensive in case we use it she's yes be
careful she's uh
she's efficient with money she's frugal
she doesn't
want to overspend on things that she
doesn't need to overspend exactly she
doesn't want she's not wasteful
great
and um she's also
really like she listens to msnbc all day
all day like loudly because she has now
trouble hearing um and so it's just
inundated with like and then and covet
is rising in the midwest and you know
and like and trump did another thing and
it's always it's like so every time i go
over there it's like did you hear what
trump did or did you hear that kovit is
rising you know it's and it's like mom
you have to
just turn it off um your mom and my mom
need to hang out my mom is
at all times i will call her
tansy i love it she's gonna be so
excited she's been mentioned but
she
you know will be in the middle of a
really special like deep conversation as
women and
she'll be like
oh sorry rachel's on i gotta go and i'm
like rachel okay rachel okay you're done
you're done yes their friend uh same
thing their friend rachel um
and it was chris before uh
who
who got kind of
did he get kicked off did he he's he's
done he's not okay okay he's um
yeah he so they they're like so she's
wild now about by the way tansy is such
a great name
i know well her name is constance and
well actually
her i think on her birth certificate it
says constance but her mother called her
constanza which i'm like
and then she went by connie in high
school and now tansy and i was like
tansy is a great bold choice yes
like to go from like connie in high
school to be like i'm tansy now i i love
the confidence no
no
tansy and ron and ron is such a like
stop like american you know yeah
man yeah cowboy he's from montana and
oh wow ron and tansy they're just like
how did how did it how did it work how
did it happen
well but i imagine they were lovely
you are and like inventive and curio
were you like
were they good about fostering your
creativity and your curiosity as a kid
were they um i think they had to because
i was just
i have a feeling we were similar kids
were you a wild kid in terms of like
zap zooms out
yes i wasn't performancy but bounce i
was always doing stuff i always wanted
to be outside at nature i loved like
exploring i wanted to find critters and
i was really into fishing like outside i
wanted to do stuff hands and you're
still the same way you're still the same
right yeah you still like frogs yeah i
do yes
i do
i not much has changed yeah they were
good parents yeah
yeah you grew up in montana
no i grew up in las vegas that's where
they met and had me and my sister and
and i was definitely uh to answer your
question a little wild child but i i uh
i i did a lot of i did improv at like
eight years old i started teaching i
read that that's so easy
i know
i didn't even know they had classes for
kids that yeah who knew i just well also
i'm like was that around in the early
90s i didn't even know that i know
it's the same way i feel about hummus
and like was hummus around when i was a
kid or was that just like not a thing in
america
yeah i know i know i don't remember
there being a lot of that's
around and now i get hummus everywhere
um
everywhere
what inspired them to put i mean
obviously like you must have been a very
performance oriented kid but
was it specifically about
acting do they see potential in your
performing in that regard i think so i
think you know
i'm like my dad so my dad went to the
movies every sunday of his whole life so
uh yeah so and he always took me with
him and
and so i grew up loving movies and you
know even at a young age i mean my
favorite thing in the world was to just
go to blockbuster and roam around and
like i miss that experience and there's
some movies that i still have never seen
but i know their vhs cover better than
anything
like i'm like oh i know that movie
well chill i i saw this documentary
about 80s movies like horror
specifically horror movies in the 80s um
like the rise of the slasher
movie and um oh and and they said that
that had a lot to do with it with the
proliferation of horror movies was
because uh those
those videocassette when video became
big in the 80s uh the artwork for those
vhs boxes was that was all that sold the
movies that was like yeah um and so they
started getting really detailed about
you know and they started paying a lot
of attention to the artwork on the vhs
and i and
similarly there are movies because we
weren't allowed to see our r-rated
movies but i was fascinated by the art
rated you know artwork and like there's
still movies i remember i feel like i've
seen them just from from the cover i was
fascinated by them fully there was um uh
this is kind of a silly story i
i i got in a little bit of trouble as a
kid because my parents got called in for
a parent teacher conference because we
did santa claus list around december and
i was in
i had to be in second grade or something
like that
and i wrote my list to santa and they
showed other children's examples of
their santa clauses so it was like
barbies or gi joes or things like that
they're like here's your daughters and
it was
it said
uh
a copy of misery silence of lambs
and copycat which is uh
i don't know if you remember that
harry potter junior
yes and holly hunter by the way there's
a thriller
and guess what give it a re-watch i've
watched it twice this year i'm not going
to lie to you
making up for lost times as i said yeah
yeah
but yeah i just i've never seen my my
mom was like she thinks i let you see
these movies i'm like i've never seen
them but i was just so
obsessed with like the hype over them
and the art and the and they were so
forbidden they were so like untouchable
yeah
what was the other one it was silenced
the lambs the copycat misery
misery yeah which i just rewatched too
and um obviously the incapacitated stuff
and the hobbling stuff that was all wild
to me but um oh my gosh that shot of her
breaking oh
but wait can i ask you a question
because we have to worry about it what
is it like being in the modern day
uh misery with tess oh oh
you know what's funny i thought about
tusk today because it i live in a town i
live in connecticut in a town called
south park southport and there is like a
um
there's a shop called tusk that i think
is like uh kind of fancy it's in like a
it's in like a fancy little main street
area and i think it's um but a big sign
tusk and i think it's like uh home maybe
home goods i don't know what they do but
i think it's very like
fancy like bed bath and beyond type
thing or like our anthropology type
store um but but it's it's the last
thing that should make me think of that
movie and yet i'm nervous for you to go
in there what if they're like we got
them
uh yeah it's all a setup it was a really
expensive
yeah they just have like all of it has
like little knickknacks and things it's
just irony it's just like an irony
and then and a net just falls on your
head and they grab you well they have i
have a someone gave me a walrus uh head
so i have this like fake walrus head
that i i have
and i it's kind of cool but i don't know
if i should put it up a because it's
like
a little grotesque it's like a
it's a walrus head and i wouldn't know
where to put it but it's also like
weirdly
self-referential i guess like i don't
yeah i don't know where
so
for two reasons i've yet to hang and i'm
lazy uh i have i have
something uh disgusting on that same
note to show you which is um
one of the guys who did makeup on idiot
sitter a show i wrote gave
me and my friend charlotte who were the
stars of the show
as a wrap gift a present of like a
framed
sketch drawing of our faces just like
each of us and but he took the makeup he
used from like a really crazy scene
where we had it all smeared all over her
face the actual map sent it to the
artist and they incorporate it into the
drawing and it's really
and that is cool
so i was like
i don't know maybe just like in the
office or somewhere that's not like
you open the door of my house and you
see a parlor yeah
but the thing is is that someone i knew
and this is very sad but someone i knew
during the pandemic not for copic
reasons but someone passed away and we
did like a zoom
funeral and i wasn't thinking
and i set myself up in a corner of the
office and then i went on and it's me
with a picture of myself
behind me and i
immediately
pushed the camera down and then sat like
in the smallest part of the corner with
my
shoulder up
the entire
funeral because i was
mortified that people thought i
no no i can't be like here you go
it's sorry it's a joke yeah yeah yeah oh
my god it's um it's your tuban moment
it was it was waiting you're jeffrey
two-bit moment
the jeffrey tubin
you know jeffrey toobin was the man oh
i'm so glad i'm both glad and now
hesitating to that i can tell you about
jeffrey toobin jeffrey toobin was a
he was a cnn anchor
um and he was on a meeting with other
cnn rep people
and he
thought his camera was off and he began
to pleasure himself have you not heard
about this
what oh juliet i'm sorry that i'm the
one breaking this but i'm also kind of
honored to be telling you about because
i obviously find this really funny yeah
he masturbated on fully on a zoom he was
visible to everyone
and um
and everyone saw everyone on the zoom
spot yeah
and he
i think he resigned briefly yeah you
should it's a fun google well you have
to but he's better you have to he's back
yes better than ever
he's he's gotten that out of his system
so to speak
i love that that's my jeffrey two good
moment those things to me are always so
intimidating because i
if you say something on a zoom
especially like on a group zoom
you now have are front and center you
know you are naturally very quick and i
mean i've seen you perform i peop people
have seen you
do improv so it's like do you feel
pressured to be like
funny or uh you know
contribute in in a funny way like a
single oh
a thousand percent not to get yeah too
deep or lit's um
yeah yeah one of one of my therapy
sessions was just about
who i
have to be according to maybe on the
zoom call like i know that's silly but
like let's talk about it
it's like i literally i'm like okay so
not only do i have to be one of the
smartest people on the calls like that's
the pressure i put myself i have to be
really smart i have to be really funny
and witty keep things light
i have to come in with some suggestion
that no one's ever thought of before
that helps save the day why
who needs the day to be safe like these
are all things that i've decided and so
i put a post-it on my computer for a
really long time during the pandemic
just saying like huh
you actually don't have to be everything
on this call like sometimes you just
have to show up and support other people
sometimes you you do have to run it but
like you don't have to have all the
answers to everything like some of the
smartest people will be honest and say
i actually don't know enough about that
let me research a little bit and get
back to you
i also admire when people say they don't
know there's something very human about
it and i find myself relating a lot
easier to people who
don't always know things and aren't
always on and you know there's something
comforting to that but you also do have
this background and
so much of what you do
relies on um
a an in the moment response you know
being good at responding
so how how is there any way to even
answer this i don't know how did you
cultivate that that sense how did you
cultivate that
that ability um was it from doing
classes or have you always just been
naturally good at um
at saying yes and
well thank you i i took a lot of classes
over groundlings like when i was 18 i
went to college for a semester and i
told my parents i want to come out to la
for what would be a semester and then i
started taking classes at the
groundlings and i'm like i'm never
coming back this is all i want to do and
um
and i just love the idea i mean i grew
up watching snl and
yeah saying that was the goal like my
whole life i didn't even go to new york
as a kid because i was like we can't go
there i want to i want to audition for
snl the first time i go to new york oh
wow that's fine
it was were your parents like what did
they
what did they think of that dancing
they're just like well
i don't know if we can let our you know
eight-year-old dictate where we're going
on vacation but they agreed to it they
agreed to never go there and then i
actually the first time i went to new
york was auditioned for
no [ __ ] that's crazy wow but but i think
it's all to answer your question i think
it's a combination of like
very
very lucky to get supportive uh not only
supportive parents but my sister the i
know you're very close with your brother
as well like such a supportive
family union unit yeah then
and then
with improv if you make someone laugh
it's such an instant like gratification
like you feel like you're like oh i i
can do this and
if you if you get you know a laugh or an
applause after something you're like
okay let me just keep working on what
works what doesn't work and and so
you're constantly honing that skill a
little bit and yeah
and so
stepping out and doing more dramatic
things is so interesting now like i feel
like i'm so
it it throws me in a way that i'm like
i'm uncomfortable but i think that's
good but also like i can't go for the
thing that's so easy to just yeah no i'm
doing
exactly the the little bell the little
pavlovian
whatever that bell is like um
yeah and yet it doesn't surprise me that
you've made this
this very easy transition to drama
because i remember seeing you at the
groundlings and
you what you had a presence that was
that was rooted in honesty like
regardless of whether it was funny or
not it was um
i'll never forget that um when you were
the anchor woman and you saw ghosts
everywhere like that was one of my
favorite bits you did because it was but
it was also you were so committed to it
i've been talking a lot about this a lot
because i'm so into
um mcgruber the new macgruber series and
like oh i can't wait to see it oh man
but what will forte and everyone like
kristen bake oh you're gonna love it but
they're so
just so committed um
and
i think it's the same
muscle that you need to use that you
need to flex it to do drama i don't
think there's any real
for me there isn't you know that it's
either you're just playing different
intentions but you were so committed
even back then like i remember uh how
how strong you were you never seemed to
go for the laughs i never saw you going
for laughs you were
you just kind of like committed to the
to the moment and
i think that's all it is that's just
acting
oh no i i uh
it's rare to see so you you
you really like remember it when you see
it um
that's one of my that's one of my
favorite sketches and it's like a dream
one day to get to host snl or do
something like that to actually do that
sketch because yeah i can't believe you
remember that that's so wild oh wow yeah
really well i remember i mean because i
knew taryn a little bit but i knew nick
pines i knew some people because i go
and like
i i and you were always one that i was
like for sure sometimes you see people
and whatever i don't want to like
embarrass you but i just always i always
knew i always
you see you see it it's really clear um
but and and then you you you didn't get
in the cast but you did get into the
writer's room yeah
what was where was that like a year
right right i actually met you
for the first time at snl
you you came
and i
like you came into the room like 2008
yeah it was 2000 eight or nine i think
it was yeah
and um
and i was just like i can't believe this
person knows who i am because you're
saying
and i was like uh
just overwhelmed in general just by like
going from i mean i was
24
and i
was moving to new york after one meeting
and like that's crazy just picking up
and moving there and and
and writing for this place it's such an
establishment and it's like yeah
all of my icons have been through there
and
and uh and you're like you're writing
for such long hours but like yeah you
just you just feel like you're like the
worst version of you like broken out and
like
just constantly
gaining weight and all of it's wonderful
and horrible and you're just like
you can't believe that you know you walk
around a corner and i remember there was
my first episode i got something on the
air
and
i think
lauren michael's thought i had potential
and then like completely lost it after
the second episode i was there because
he's like never mind never again but the
first episode i had to begin so i think
he like thought like
maybe she'll stick around because he
invited me to his group at his uh his
room that sounds very different
he invited me to his office
which is a room by the way yes yes
um he invited me to his office and he
was like oh this is um he's like oh you
mean um this is martin short that was
like
yeah oh my god
i know
who you are and she was so sweet and
kind and i was just like is this what
happens every day and and
little by little it was like
you're you're just amazed by how much it
changes your life
[Music]
i was recently shooting a movie a fun
christmas movie in utah and uh the only
downside to shooting in utah i found was
that the air was so dry it really
overnight dried out my skin i got really
um i don't want to get into details it's
a little disgusting but it's almost like
i had um facial dandruff and what what
cured me well
curology did a couple weeks earlier i
had taken a brief online quiz the
curology quiz
and uploaded some photos they shipped
this formula right to my door and it
even had my name on the bottle they gave
me a moisturizer and a cleanser and a
couple other things to really target my
skin because obviously everybody's skin
is different i gotta say i use this the
moisturizer especially
worked like a dream it worked um
overnight so you can get started with
curology just like i did with a free
30-day trial at curology.com
long just pay five dollars for shipping
and handling that's it you just pay five
dollars for shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash long to start your free
30-day trial that's free for five
dollars for the shipping and handling
you can cancel anytime and the
prescription is subject to consultation
[Music]
is it hard then to like put that aside
is it hard to set that stuff aside and
like
kind of hunker down and work and and
and be funny in that environment
i mean i think because you're around
some of the funniest people with like
the kids and the crew writing all the
time that you sort of always kept up
with that and it's like lauren michaels
is so
such a presence he's so intimidating
that you just kind of always like yeah
i want to please father like you just
want to do well in his eyes
and uh so there was always a little bit
of a fire under my butt
what did you do for your audition oh i
did i did the
news reporter oh yeah
yeah so good
i did this old
vegas show woman named beverly scarsdale
who
she was like she's like pantyhose on and
one of them one of the feats pulled out
so far she's just wasted and she's
really bitter that they're kicking her
out for tony braxton tony braxton is
coming in and taking over and uh she's
really upset so snl it was a year was
that your choosing or was it
theirs no no no no it was theirs
they made that decision they were very
clear on how do i ask this
yeah
um
it no they were they decided that but at
the same time there you know there's
obviously a summer in between when you
find out and that summer i actually went
and shot
a pilot with um somebody's mind which
was workaholics so
oh my god you were all right
so i ended up being like you know a door
closes and then oh dear lord another
door comes around yes i love those doors
i love when that also i didn't know this
that it led to
paul thomas anderson casting you in a
couple movies now i didn't know that
that he was how wild that
first of all that i i it kind of makes
sense because i know he's married to
maya rudolph and he's he's
well versed in like the comedy world
that must have been such a super that
must have been like a very bizarre
surprise
so wild i remember showing up
we were shooting in vallejo california
which is
now the name of my dog i named my dog
after that experience um and we i
you know saw him and he came over he's
like oh hey i'm i'm sorry the part's not
that big and i'm like what are you
talking about like i'm just gonna
watch i mean for for
over a month every day you know we were
sitting there i mean there was a group
of us that were around the same age it
was like rami malek jesse plemmons like
it was this is the master
yeah the master yes yeah people and we
were all just sitting around like
watching philip seymour hoffman and
you know amy adams and lord dern and and
joaquin phoenix perform i mean it was
just like
that was like
my college experience i was like what is
what like just watching my first day
it's like fantasy camp
it is it's full-on fantasy camp my my
first day was philip seymour hoffman
giving a wedding toast to oh yes his his
daughter and
her new husband robbie malik and yeah
and it's just he did it all day and he
did it in so many different ways
and i was just like
i i was just like oh this is that an
actor this is what actor yeah this is
like just take note of it and it was
really cool because
joaquin and
philip had like such different i feel so
gross just saying their personalities
you worked with them you're allowed i
almost did it with lauren michaels i
said lauren and then i corrected myself
by saying i think that one's okay i
think that one's okay but i can't say
phillip that was the most grossest thing
i've ever phil you could call him you
you worked with him yeah but i don't
know so
anyway he was the best there was one
year shooting and i had to do a scene
with him in in
marquin phoenix is inside this house
that we were shooting we were out on the
porch and he's supposed to be like
walking from one wall to the other and
just touching it
like the window to the wall or whatever
and like
and
and we are and you know joaquin is so in
it and so method that he did it the
whole day to like four in the morning
like he just did oh
my god
so he's doing that and i'm sitting out
on the porch with like
philip seymour hoffman a few other
people and we're all supposed to be
eating lunch and then
he notices that i i'm not eating any of
the radishes on my plate so he's like
what's wrong with the radishes i was
like
oh yeah i just don't i don't love him
and he's like oh and my name in it was
something like
let's say it's like mrs peterson or
something
you know throw together their name but
it was like miss peterson and so the
beginning of each take he would go this
is peterson would you like some more
wrath shouldn't you just keep dumping
that like of course he goes
just eating amazing
that's [ __ ] hilarious that's funny
phil hoffman you're me you mean it would
do that yeah while walking he's pacing
back and forth yeah yeah touching the
wall that's why so
and i was just like this is a memory
forever like i was such a baby and i
just was so oh my god every time you see
radishes yeah yeah that's cool that is
really cool um yeah wow and what and i
also want to know about um another one
of my favorites of
from that you did was uh the midriff the
bare midriff classic kirby enthusiasm
episode
also another like
the bat you're working with the greatest
the great because i had jerry seinfeld
in the two and i didn't know oh yes oh
really
no had no clue because how that show
works is like wow i don't want you to
prepare anything so
i would walk to sit there like hey
someone wants to meet you and they're
like hi i'm jerry seinfeld we're about
to be in the scene together and i was
like oh great and then they'd hand me
the sides
i had to get out and it was like
eight pieces of information and they
were like you got it and like the camera
guys already have the cameras on their
shoulders and i was like
here we go and wait wait wait jill they
give it to you the day of they give it
to you when you get what
yeah no you don't know not even not even
just the day of for me they were giving
it to me
[Music]
five minutes before we were shooting so
i couldn't plan anything oh my god so
you know
you obviously you're wearing the midriff
thing the bare minute that i knew like
when i auditioned it was
all we knew was you're playing larry's
assistant who is wearing a crop top and
then your jeans are like too tight so
you have like muffin you know whatever
and and and they said
and the only thing that you need to know
about it is like
you feel that you should be able to wear
that and i was like okay great and then
i to the audition and i had no idea
who's going to be there and i was
everyone was freaking out um because
they all knew and i had no clue
wow
yeah well so you get your information
and then like you
oh man i would be my head would be
swimming but but like that's the thing
about having the training that you had
is like
i you seem so poised and and relaxed you
seem so that's part of the the joke in
fact in that scene i'm not telling you
i'm telling people is that like you were
so relaxed you were just like so blase
yeah
yes you have no you don't give him any
status i love that you you give him no
well
i kept calling him larry because i was
like if i do this i'll feel like i'm at
his level if if i
don't i'll just feel like i'm like
again
yeah
i just kept saying larry there's
probably a drinking game you can do with
it
says larry yes
yes
was it was it like at what point do you
allow yourself to freak like
the moment of oh freak out like oh my
god i just did a scene with jerry
seinfeld and i think
when
it was wrapped i wanted to
i
and that's the other thing too is like
yeah i i can't believe you've never have
you never done curb
no you would be so good on it um
they don't tell you like they'll like i
didn't even know it was a guest star
like they literally were like
so we're gonna have you come back
tomorrow and i was like oh okay like you
didn't know really
holy [ __ ] i don't know if they've
changed it now because i'm sure like
they have such like massive stars on
that show now i'm sure jon hamm knows
he's working tuesday thursday and friday
but i did
someone who had never done anything i
had no idea did that change thing i mean
when that show came out was that
did that change things noticeably
for you it it was interesting because i
wasn't in la after that came out i was
in work as a writer and i was sort of
you know in this weird position where
i'm trying to one pretend i'm a writer
because i oh that was before us now it
was before i shot it before us now and
it came out during smell so like i
remember seth meyers and everybody was
like oh julian you were on curb last
night i was like yeah i'd like to ask
funny so they almost have been like kind
of also probably maybe a little envious
like that's like the
that's the mountain
well i don't i don't know maybe wow like
i'll answer for them yes they were they
were
but like i am surprised that that didn't
that didn't contribute to them wanting
to keep you around i mean that they saw
it it's so clear your comedic gifts in
there that um
that's a surprise that they wouldn't see
oh oh she's part she's doing this she's
like
matching larry david and jerry it's not
like scene for scene she's like hanging
in there that's very sweet
i i had a i had a thing that i did that
like i don't think i've ever talked
about that i well i
the year after
um
i left taryn got on the show and tara
and i were very close and
yeah and we're in sunday company
together so i you know he had invited me
to come out to see the show and i was
sort of like
you know it's like seeing your ex like
you want to feel good and look good and
also do you want to see your ex how is
it that harry reacts like
so i i had this thing where i kind of
built it up in my head as if i had any
choice and it actually makes me feel
really sweet like like i like my heart
goes out to the younger version of
myself that did this where i was like
i'm gonna go
and i'm gonna see if i can just say
goodbye to this idea of ever
like being on this show
or like like closure or yeah i'm gonna
go and i'm gonna go up to learn
michael's and be like you gotta give me
a chance
and thank goodness
thank goodness for my sweet
naive self that i was like this is
closure and honestly
the reason i i felt that way is because
a couple of the writers and a couple of
the cast members told me and who knows
of this i mean i'd like to believe it's
true because they told me but
they said that they all went together
and like went to bat for me about being
in the cast which i thought was very
sweet and it's just a decision with
lauren that he just never saw it and i i
truly
i truly for a long time it was like a
heartbreak for me but i think
now
i wouldn't have been like
i always say this to my sister and
everything i'm like i wouldn't have been
around for the last years of my dad's
life if i was stuck in new york you know
i wouldn't have met my dog who is one of
the great loves of my life there i
wouldn't have done workaholics like
there was there's just a lot that ended
up happening because i wasn't there so
is it yeah isn't that interesting that i
mean when you have that perspective when
you can step back and and see it yeah
let's see it takes a while
yeah for sure for sure but like you said
i mean like the biggest one being i mean
just time that you got to have that time
fully yeah yeah um
then you got to make really your own
movie i mean you got to brittany runs a
marathon feels like it came
straight i know it's not necessarily
there a lot of people contributed but um
it felt so personal that movie uh
certainly the performance was
it's so funny i i just did a zoom game
night last night with paul downs glazo
who was the writer and director of it
and um we were saying how it feels like
we're the pandemic part is
ramping back up again that we might be
locked down a little bit but um yeah
but you know i i do feel such a
closeness to him because that was one
where we both looked at each other and
were like okay it's
there's so many people who are going to
be
creating and making this happen but if
we don't trust each other if we don't
work together on this like yeah so we've
got to throw everything into yeah and it
was such a vulnerable
project for me i mean just issues i've
had since i was a little girl i think
most yeah most women will agree and some
and a lot of events so yeah um
but i almost quit it i almost didn't do
it oh really
yeah because of that because it was
almost too vulnerable it was yeah i
didn't i didn't know if it would be
therapeutic or if it would like throw me
into some kind of spiral and and
you know a lot of times i try to
weigh that stuff out of like yeah you
know you just kind of want to
do things that you feel like
either
feel like they would be so much fun or
yeah
they
uh
they challenge you and this felt like
such a big challenge like to the point
where i was like this feels a little
daunting and my sister said to me she
agreed about she was like go to sleep
read it first thing in the morning and
if you say no then don't do it but read
it again like fresh like bright and
early in the morning yeah that is smart
and i did and i was like i have to do
this movie
hello hello again we'll meet again
[Music]
we have a lightning round
oh
exciting quick lightning round i've
already taken advantage of your time
it's we're almost we're closing in on it
what is your favorite emoji oh i think i
do um i think i do there's this it's a
smiley face that's warm with like sweet
cheeks oh roses and then it's and then
it's got three hearts around its head
like one oh yes yeah two on the bottom
or something like that i use that one a
lot yeah oh i love that one yeah just a
a love of everything that you're saying
yes yes um i would use that for this
for this
um who is
who is your first celebrity crush
uh uh
donnie wahlberg or
steven seagal
which explains my terrible taste in men
next question
[Laughter]
no no let's explore this wait donnie
well
great guys yeah who knows yeah oh
they're great yeah stephen
is a great guy well i don't know his
musical but johnny walter seems like
he's got his act together
he does he sure does and i recently
rewatched sixth sense god was he good in
that he's so good in that movie
great what a great actor um yeah who
knew i remember like i i'm recognizable
too i remember thinking somebody told me
that i thought like that was back before
like he was known to be an actor and
yeah i went to see that movie because he
was in it and i watched the whole thing
and i go where was donnie wahlberg
oh oh
i didn't know that
that must have been so disappointing if
you go to see six seven as a donny
rockwood fan
you'll be disappointed
that's really funny it's like going to
see jaws because you're a fan of whoever
plays the woman who runs out into the
water and gets
eaten
um
what is your favorite ice cream flavor
uh mint chocolate chip yes okay somebody
uh amy mann said mint chocolate chip and
she said this is gonna be controversial
or she said something about how it's
controversial and christian and i were
like
how is that god it's um some people
don't like mint some people do not like
mint they think it's gross and i i do
understand the whole the whole thing is
why would you like a treat that tastes
like a
toothpaste flavor yeah right
right i know um
what is your favorite holiday
i like halloween but i don't like the
actual halloween not like halloween
months i like october is what yeah
i like all of october because i like to
watch the scary things
but honestly i do really love a
i feel like this is controversial i do
really love a new year's eve i don't
feel like most people like it new year's
eve but
um i don't only because it's like i have
i have some issues with time passing and
like i and that's like a big another
change it's a big change and
it's also like the
there's a lot of pressure to like
have a love and to get wasted and these
things that i don't necessarily um
[Music]
uh
yeah i feel like pressure from and and
then like the whole crowd
being and watching the ball drop i've
never understood why people um wanna
yeah
before the pandemic random one it's a
random one to pick because i think
but i don't mean to [ __ ] on you this is
your choice no i feel like [ __ ] now i
feel like a piece
what kind of answer is that there are no
wrong answers but that is wrong
what was it like going on justin long's
podcast well i'll tell you
i'll tell you you made me really like
hate myself what what do you have a
tradition like a new year's eve
tradition
well i mean
growing up in vegas you couldn't really
do anything until you were 21. so i feel
like it was a lot of like
i don't know going to someone else's
house for like a fake champagne toast
but now as an adult
i feel like i
i i normally have a little thing i mean
not since the pandemic obviously but i
normally have a thing at my house and i
i don't know it's just like it just
feels warm and it's so nice to like not
be going anywhere have everyone force
everyone to come to you and
you just have like a nice champagne
toast and just
i don't know
do you get to see your yours is your
sister in vegas though so my sister and
i cool fact live together
and
we work together as producers and oh
[ __ ]
we're
best bestest friends oh man well you
know i relate to that what's your name
brianna
oh brianna uh that's great i'm so i like
hearing that um
i i i it's arrogant that i like hearing
that because it reminds me of me
um
what a jerk
yeah what is what is an acclaimed movie
show that you you
haven't seen but like people kind of
shame you for not seeing like you
haven't seen what
uh the godfather what is a game show
pastor president that you'd want to be a
contestant on
oh i yeah i gotta go with the prices
right because that's like all i watch
when i was kid on sick days oh yeah
totally yes
uh yeah i i don't think i'd be very good
at it but i i i i don't think i'd be
good at it either but i'd be so excited
i want i want to hold the mic although i
don't know if this is still there then
one like a pen
uh i have you gotten to do any of those
like celebrity
like family any of the like game shows i
did the
uh what was the game that alec baldwin
was hosting oh watch game um no
is it match game uh yeah i think it was
yeah it's the one where you have to get
that game you have to other person is
yes guessing there are two contestants
and then their panel yeah that's a fun
one he's so good at that i know so good
so good
um but that was really fun have you done
one before
i did that i did um we recently
christian and my brother and i got to do
family feud which was that's fun [ __ ]
fun yeah that was gosh he we and we all
had a classic family feud moment which
was a good and bad family feud moment it
was the best
where we like missed the the obvious
thing and then we like guessed the good
we had so we all got to have like a
really and good interactions with steve
harvey who i think is hilarious
were your parents on it too
no no they because it was during cove
they didn't want to they were afraid to
fly out
you're one of my favorite instagram
posts of yours is you watching your
mother in the commercial she was in
was it oh
oh my god and the guy says something
like
that's good [ __ ] or something is
something
horrible like that it's oh that's a good
pizza peanut that tastes like peanuts
or something that tastes like peanuts
well that tastes like peanuts
it's so good i showed my whole family
that cause like this is such a belfast
moment too so that's great
she has some really good classic ones
she was in one uh an uh entenmann's
commercial where she like woke up in the
middle of the night what your parents
is your sister how old is she
she's 42.
oh she might remember this then there is
an entrance commercial where in the
middle of the night uh
one of them wakes up and she and my mom
wakes up and she's like um i really want
whatever
strudel or apple something and and then
it cuts to her and the husband's like go
back to sleep and it cuts to her like
running out in the rain to get it
but i i
i remember it because i i the kids in
school after it was on would
i guess they were teasing me i didn't
realize at the time but they were like
we saw your mom in bed with another man
and i was like
well yeah i uh yeah the commercial i
didn't know i was like yeah she did i
i yeah i didn't get that they thought it
was weird or and i didn't get the sexual
implication either that like
so what so i'll be in a bed with anyone
what's weird about that oh my gosh that
is that is fully like um i saw mommy
kissing santa claus like how that went
over my head for until like i'm 37 35
probably 35 i got it
i was like 35 at christmas listening
what
yes i know i never got an implication
that's true i know
do you drink coffee or tea
and how do you take it neither i don't
drink either i don't drink caffeine um
at all because
fun fact for your listeners i have
kidney stones
heyo
heyo it's me and we're just like
oh my god
wow
no i didn't know how did that
wait is that some is that a permanent
condition so
uh you're more prone to them if you if
you've ever experienced it uh no one in
my family that i know has had them but
wow i had like two years where i was
like well i guess i just will always
have back pain for the rest of my life
oh
man i finally
you know it was like the third time of
me going to the er being like i need
something for my back problems that
someone was finally like let's do
let's do like a scan and see if there's
anything on there and the guy was like
you have
like
so many kidney stones that they had to
do three procedures to take them out so
i was like jesus nothing nothing anymore
so just drink this is a starbucks cup
full of water
yes julian just held up sorry yeah do
you you didn't order that at starbucks
you didn't order a water well yes i did
i ordered it once every once in a while
i'll go with this give the starbucks
i'll be like i'll be wild and i'll get
something to eat and then i'll get a
venti ice water because i'm like it
makes me feel like i'm a person
yes you just want to hear him call your
name yeah yeah i just really love
hearing people call my name
wait
jillian bell and it's the whole name
hoping that someone like yes here that's
me star of yes yes
um you don't have to write out britney
runs a marathon's jillian bell you don't
have to
but so it's it's the um it is just the
caffeine it's is that what yeah i think
i think i was
uh i was a
soda enthusiast
and i drank a lot of it
me too
it got to the point i mean what was your
favorite what's your favorite ruby i
loved root beer i love birch beer oh my
gosh so good it was my favorite um
in fact sometimes i'll see like a a w or
like a hot like an old you know fashion
and i'll just really mugs i'll miss uh
it sounds so good i like you know even
even like i had to
grieve watching movies and movie
theaters with no soda like that was yeah
big part of the experience yeah
what was your go-to soda
i mean
i'm trash so
doc
dr pepper
mister said mr pibb oh
i mean i did i said it right after
dr pepper on classy nights i mean this
is like literally i feel like
picking doc remember mr pip is like your
number one is like the equivalent of
being like i used to do drugs what drugs
heroines yeah yeah it's like well pcps
and crystal meth
and i'm so sorry of one of your sponsors
is mr pam i really apologize oh i
thought you're gonna say it was crystal
meth
no no if if it is i'm shameless we'll
cut it all out or we'll just dub in us
saying nice things oh yeah
it's like just me saying sprite
yes
some bad jillian bell impression is you
know i love mr pibb
um
it was it's so bad for you i i didn't
when i drink it now on the rare
occasions of like i don't know when i
would try soda but the few times i have
it's like
isn't it crazy how sweet it tastes yes
it's like
well and the thing is too i'm
i'm a taurus uh i don't know what
signing or what sign are you i'm a
gemini gemini okay so
i go really hard with stuff so like the
same way that i was like able to be like
i'm going to lose 40 pounds for bernie
road
i have not had a sip of soda since the
kidney stone thing happened so like oh
oh goodness i can't even like partake a
little bit because i feel like i'll just
be like i need my hit mama needs are hit
yeah i bet also like it must have i mean
you were in so much pain that it was oh
it freaked me out it freaked me out i'm
not doing this anymore all water god
good for you i mean how much healthier
too but do you have a vice now like any
sort of um i kill people i uh oh
i am
well now i wish you were drinking
super again
yeah
uh no i'm trying to what my advice would
be i haven't i'm bad lately with
shopping i feel like this has happened
since the pandemic
where like all of a sudden i'm like
i'm like does this mean
like i'm like does this make me feel
like a pretty pretty girl and then i
just buy it i'm like ugh i need her to
turn that what am i doing i i'll i'll
forget that i bought something like
where is this from
it's so easy to order everything now
yeah yeah i bet a lot of people have
that if you could learn another language
what would it be oh probably french my
ex vote french fluently and i was always
so jealous and i would try to do it back
to him but i don't think i was saying
anything
you know like i just was like crying and
he was like so sorry that one was kind
of a word that was kind of the word
table
but he's like no
but i would love to i love to learn
fridge
yeah me too um what is your favorite
cereal oh i mean again i don't have it
anymore but cinnamon toast crunch
oh yes mine too mine too
yeah i and that i know it's i'm trying
not to eat it anymore not for the you
know anything severe like that but
i might need a severe reason and it's
good
um
and now they make uh i shouldn't tell
you this but they make a churro cinnamon
toast yeah cinnamon churro crunch
i'll be right back
okay here the car [ __ ] the kidney stones
yeah um
if you had a sandwich vallejo just jumps
into frame and yes you tell me that you
played
if you
if you had a um if you had to choose a
different first name
what would it be penny
it's always been one of my favorite
names i think it's such a sweet name i i
could see that that really fits you
penny thank you what would yours be
um my brother was just asking me today
and i was saying things like jack or
jake or things that were closer to my
own name just to make the transition
easier um
but i i used to love the name marty when
i was
oh a kid you know because they're back
because
yeah yeah
long is not my favorite last name we
both have names that are just like
bella's bell is delicate and nice and
ends on an l but
long just always falls flat so you have
to
think about the last name too right
penny bell penny bell is a cool name
penny bell
yeah um
if you had a
sandwich named after you the jillian
bell what what would be on it like what
would you what would your sandwich be
it's basically i feel like it's just the
turkey and provolone mike's way at
jersey mike's it's just that oh my god
the number eight i think yeah it's so
good
as if i'm not mistaken yeah i'm not
mistaken um i think it's this i don't
know it might be that might be the
turkey and ham i get the turkey and ham
with the mir i substitute the american
for the provolone but god do i love it
jersey mike's gosh it's so good
if you're watching the tom hank what is
your favorite tom hanks
movie well that's so hard um
favorite tom hanks movie
is probably
oh my god but there's so many this is
really tough yeah
yeah well it's there are that's kind of
why we were like
even if you're not like a huge tom hanks
fan
you're going to love a
a tom hanks movie he hasn't he's too
many good movies i mean this sounds
ridiculous because we're trying to
remake it right now but splash is one of
my favorite
oh [ __ ] no that's not really no but but
i love splash and i love big i mean big
is oh yes wait trying to remake splash
are they really
yeah we it's channing tatum and myself
and we're he's gonna play the merman and
i'm playing tom hanks's part but it's
like a reimagining oh my god amazing but
yeah it's uh we've been trying to do
that for years now we'll see if it gets
done would you rather take a time
machine to the past or the future oh
gosh these are really good questions do
you know i do this in my house no i
literally do these kind of things for my
family all the time and they hate it i
call it questions and they're like let's
just
let's just naturally hang out
well
what's one that one of them one of my
favorite ones is what what would you
name yourself if you could name yourself
and then would you add oh and then i i
like to ask like silly things like oh
would you rather live next to the ocean
or like in the woods like any of the
like name one thing yes name one night
you wish you could
redo not to change it but because you
loved it so much
what was your day that you'd redo
you know there's this one day
where my i'm i'm
really bad about planning vacations i
kind of stick in work mode too long and
then i forget about them
and then i'm 37. and then
my mom and my sister like forced me to
go to santa barbara and we stayed at
this little hotel that was like nothing
special or anything but like we bought a
bra
we bought a bottle of wine and like
just sat out and was
just like telling old stories and stuff
and the vibe of it was like no one had
anywhere to be there wasn't anything
weighing on anyone and it just felt like
we could genuinely
be adults together like it's hard when
your mom is your mom because she's your
friend but she's lost your mom yeah and
i think like we just had like a day
where we kind of dropped all of it and
just
weren't great yeah just yeah you were
like present with each other yeah um
okay so i'd go
the past movie
is there an um is there an era that you
would want most to explore i would like
to i would like to go to i mean it's
kind of cliche but i like to go to like
the
woodstock just for a day oh yeah totally
real free little baby
maybe i'm topless maybe i'm not like no
i just want to be a different person
who cares and uh and and just like
listen to music all day and smoke weed
yeah that sounds great
uh are are you more of a talker or a
texter i like to talk i'm i'm i'm okay
at texting but i like to talk i think
it's nice to hear other people's voices
although now it feels almost rude to
call people like they're like why what
what that's what has happened they must
have i just i assume everyone's butt
dialing me i know um
now i'm thinking about being at
woodstock and as cool as would i i think
i might have a bathroom issue like if
the bathrooms there might have been a
little difficult to navigate are you a
night or morning person night night
beach or mountains do you prefer the
beach this you'll this might we might be
here for a while toilet roll over or
under do you have strong feelings about
it oh over yes
why i don't what is the rationale of
under is that it's hidden i don't know i
just i think it's a small hint
that that something's wrong upstairs
i think it's a small way of saying check
in on me maybe i'm not doing well
um and julian will you finally finish
this sentence
life is short so
oh man everything i'm thinking was so
cheesy it's like no well what did we say
in the beginning i know well it's like
okay love everyone kiss who you want as
long as it's consensual oh watch the
movie clue it's a great movie and
uh
uh
skinny dip once
i've never done it actually i don't know
why i'm getting really nice and i've
never done it oh oh it's phenomenal it's
really freeing and that's what i would
think i got to do it jillian you're the
best you know i'm such a fan of yours
and i'm i'm just like you personally so
much this is such a fan of yours as well
and i would do this again again i just
want to hang out with you i was sure i
know yesterday
i would love that thank you for doing
this yeah of course
so
that just happened
why did we get um
well because she can be a little
she can be she knows when to be quiet
she has she she plays with her tonality
i think her volume yeah in a in a fun
way don't you think like she's it's
funny to say that about an adult though
she knows how to be quiet she's like no
i hope so she's not a maniac not not in
a like she's disciplined sense
she's always screaming
she's um
she's she but she does that with her
comedy she is confident with it which
was why it was interesting to explore
some of her um when she lacks cotton or
when she struggles with confidence you
know because she's always seemed to me
too that's surprising yeah it always is
to me with good performers like that but
but her in particular because she does
do
it is really gutsy to do some of the
stuff that she does and and and patient
to play with moments of silence she's
not afraid to
let an awkward moment kind of like
sit there and
oftentimes you feel
comedic performers wanting to fill the
silence and yeah she's very she's got it
which has always struck me that she has
a good understanding of common she has a
good sense of humor yeah you know i mean
sometimes people people can be really
good performers and good actors and not
necessarily
funny people but it's also that idea
that you can be both
you know people are complicated so a
person can be both
fearless on stage doing improv and
have insecurities about how they
come across on a zoom meeting yeah like
not it's not black and white and i i was
struck by that with her i i've been
struck by that in the past with other
guests like bobby moynihan strikes me as
someone who is
seems like he would never be insecure
about anything but yet he does these
fearless things on stage
in front of you know iconic like lauren
michaels i really relate to that i i do
i mean i i've have when i socially or
the thought of going out in public or
being at a dinner party i um i have a
lot of anxiety about it and people might
find that hard to believe like our
parents would never believe no that
about you i say that to my mother and
she immediately oh you oh justin come on
yeah but i died you never get scared she
like really doesn't believe you no like
aggressively doesn't believe you no so
i've given up trying to convince her but
um maybe you can convince all the
listeners strangers a lot more people
listening than just our mother that's
true i hope that's true that's true the
stakes are a little higher with our
mother but um yeah that that is
a truthful statement about myself and so
i when i hear somebody like julian say
that it shouldn't surprise me because i
i relate to that and and there is a real
comfort in uh when you're on when i'm on
stage or in front of a camera there's a
real comfort in the time between action
and cut it it just feels very liberating
and maybe it's because there aren't as
many rules as there are in life or or
you don't have to be yourself you know
you can hide i i i was watching um
there's we've been watching love on the
spectrum this great netflix series about
people on the spectrum who are looking
for love and
and
uh one of them described their love of
cosplay
as a way to be out in the world and be
comfortable in the world because they
get to kind of hide behind a character
and i've known it the the few
conventions the horror movie conventions
whatever i've been to i've i've noticed
that there are a lot of people who
seem like they could be on the spectrum
they're
in in character presenting themselves as
like a
whether it's a heroic or a sexy or
whatever some other character it was
really yeah i suppose the psychology
isn't all that different then no you're
you're not on the spectrum but
the way you describe
uh the freedom and the safety of playing
a character is not that difficult oh no
no i totally related to that to people
who you know who use cosplay in that in
that way
is it cosplay or cosplay because
you know i know it's cos but is it
pronounced costs or cause
and if you dressed up as bill cosby
would have built a cosplay
cancel
uh speaking of snl uh she
only lasted one year on that show which
is surprising and also now
you know objectively i on her behalf i
have this i have this sense of
i guess she got the last laugh because
she has this great career i know and
she's starring in movies i didn't want
to say that but i was thinking that and
i'm sure that has i would guess i'm not
sure i would guess that's crossed her
mind at some point but i think she has a
very healthy
i have much healthier approach to it in
that when she talked about you know one
one door closes another door open so she
kind of alluded to the the idea that
well yeah that was a huge bummer but
then
the next f that fall i started you know
shooting totally workaholics oh
i think that's a very healthy approach
to rejection in general i do too and
there was no similar to how zach levi um
felt about
you know the kids who used to make fun
of him and seeing them again after his
success it
there's not a lot of value you learn
this too there's one thing to like think
about you know fantasize about oh man if
i ran into that bully and i'll show him
and look what i have now but then
when you actually get those things and
you have that success and that status
whatever that is
i i think it's natural with people like
that i think it's a good instinct to to
to not find the value in in flaunting it
or
rubbing it in people's faces it's mature
it's mature and evolved yeah yeah so
she's mature and evolved yeah i'm glad
you settled that yeah
um i was surprised she didn't know about
the jeffrey toobin i was scandal i
thought that scandal was i thought it
was very common
too i immediately became
uh embarrassed that i was going to have
to be the one to explain this to her and
like i don't want to be in any way
attached to i know it could have been
you could have had to explain it to uh
dr jane goodall oh no i would i would i
would have had to that's one of those
rare instances where i think you have to
lie
yeah i think you parachuted away oh now
who was jeffrey who's jeffrey i'm sorry
i don't know this person by the way
jeffrey two but it's crazy what happened
what he did it's not crazy what he did
it's crazy what he did on camera right
that's the thing it's crazy but he is
he's back now yes and i think part of
the reason he's back is because
he is
excellent at what he does he's he's an
incredibly good writer yeah journalist
yeah so it's like and it's also i but
it's crazy what he did it it is but
morally is it crazy it's it's something
it's something that a most let's say
it's not crazy that people did that it's
crazy that he the timing of it not only
on camera but like but the immediacy the
compulsion right now to do it while
other people are talking that is very
strong that he was able to
get there mentally
with
i know i mean can you imagine doing that
listening to like espn or watching espn
no i don't think i could do it no i
don't
i don't either but espn forget that
having like colleagues i know i'm seeing
i'm trying i was trying to think of a
milder scenario and even much easier to
do it watching espn without
people i know i mean gun to the head i
could do it
actually
depends on what you're kicking i bet i
could i could get guns to the head cut
to the head i'd be too scared i mean
you'd have to i'd be like that's why
performance can imagine talk about
performance anxiety this is a crazy
thing to picture i know oh she knows
that you like frogs that was funny yeah
it's not funny that people know you like
frogs because of instagram
because it's like the majority of what i
post on instagram
she's like i'm i like vaguely know that
you're an actor but i know you're a
i think i know you have a friend
enthusiast frogs yeah um she loves
cinnamon toast crunch yeah as do i but i
think i both have to love cinnamon toast
an important transition i've made with
cinnamon toast crunch over the last i
would say
five years
has been the way i see it now in terms
of breakfast versus
i know me too that's a big change once
you start seeing cinnamon toast crunch
as a dessert
it's a game changer you know when i
think of cinnamon toast crunch what do
you think of what does your brain do
anything when you hear the word cinnamon
toast crunch together
um does it
well i don't know what you're asking
well i guess i should just say what it
does to me is i can all i can hear is
cinnamon toast crunch doesn't do that
for me oh wow that that jingle was so
uh
so impactful to me it might have been
more not before i remember it it rings
cinnamon and sugar we're baking up a
bunch we got the cinnamon i remember it
it definitely rings a bell yeah
but that might have been a little that
might have been like mid eight mid to
late maybe vibes that's when you know a
uh jingle really cinnamon toast great
jingle do you ever go by like the golden
arches and here
uh
no but whenever um i i'm in the
supermarket and i pass by the folgers
which is crazy remember how often those
commercials folgers in your cup oh yeah
all the time and it's like
who buys folgers you never
i haven't seen it true
in years oh really but i always see it
in supermarkets yeah me too but i don't
know anyone who
drinks folgers well where would you be
around i mean who you'd have to go to
somebody's house sure i go to people's
houses you do i guess maybe not a lot
really maybe people still drink folger's
coffee i bet they do you see it but i
maybe it's the but it but i guess my
point is
the rise of
starbucks and these big coffee chains i
feel like getting coffee
like making coffee at home and like
instant coffee at home is
feels like a thing of the past because
coffee is so easily accessible now in
the world in like a chain way was this
too much of a leap though but maybe
people people still must be drinking
but here's another reason you never see
the commercials anymore whereas when
you're kids they're absolutely on that
is strange maybe because we don't watch
the same things think about this they
were on when we were watching like
daytime tv we don't watch a lot of
daytime maybe or is it because
because folgers already has such a
consumer base oh maybe they don't need i
think about pepperidge farm
pepperidge farms you never see like
a new milano flavor or like university
commercials for chessmen which by the
way pepperidge farm representatives if
you're listening
here's all you need to do you just have
to feed this is our it has always been
our idea for commercial we shouldn't
probably talk about it just feed
somebody who loves something i.e me and
chessmen
just watch somebody is it gross to watch
somebody eat something i think it's
gross but it's also funny to picture a
30 second commercial it's just you
sitting on a folding chair eating chess
men and enjoying them but i think
i also think it might be effective i do
too
maybe we shouldn't also feel the tea
people say yes yes also speaking of
spill attracting sponsors you got you
and jillian bell both talked about how
much you like
jersey mike's oh yeah and josie mike if
you're listening hey come on what what
you won't regret being a sponsor and now
we both love we love we'll jersey mike
we will happily talk about a lot of it
and we will sing your praises well if i
work for jersey we'll do it for free i
guess that's the thing i'd be like well
what do you why should we pay them
they're already
doing it unsolicited but what did i get
you for your birthday jersey mike's
among other things you got me a hundred
dollar jersey mike's that is almost gone
oh it is yeah there's like i have like
30 bucks left
you said yeah so like sheepishly yeah
well i'm not proud of that yeah like
once a week it is so good though and uh
yeah you know who doesn't eat jersey
mike's probably because he's
in too good of shape she barely never
eats carbs
um channing tatum oh
yeah who's uh hopefully future friend of
the show and he's making
they're working on making uh splash
a reimagining of sp splash splash
i i have to text him about that i don't
know why i don't think i've ever asked
him to be on the only thing that was
um surprising to me about her saying
that is
that it's taken
years to develop it
channing tatum as a merman
in that getup does not seem like such a
layout
i feel like they can start shooting that
tomorrow and like anyone who
here's how much money investigates you
need i know you could do that with it's
co-starring i mean i'm glad jillian's
doing it but it could be co-starring any
yeah you could be like with kevin spacey
maybe not maybe not or bill cosby yeah
yeah full circle uh should we full
circle should we read a letter should
you read a letter rather yes
here we go
this is a letter from
it just says just a little letter
subject just a little letter
hello christian and justin and the
person mining these letters for a winner
i've noticed that a lot of the people
who write and share horrible things that
have happened to them are tragedies a
prerequisite for having a letter read on
the show if so stop reading immediately
i've only managed to contract i've only
managed to contract moderate scoliosis
and a case of near a nearsightedness ah
you have moderate scoliosis and your
sightiness oh yeah
did you write this um
i faced some rejection in life but who
hasn't god gave me a pair of fantastic
parents and an older sister who's all
right jk she's a rad little genius my
work life leaves her older sister
yes is a rad
she must be small
because you wouldn't refer to your older
sibling as little right unless they were
little maybe she's saying she's not not
a big genius she's not like einstein
she's a little genius oh okay okay sorry
to interrupt i don't know my my work
life leaves something to be desired
though
it is why i started listening to your
podcast you see my work involves a lot
of mindless invoicing and your podcast
keeps my brain engaged that's still nice
also the business owner gets yelly with
only the thin suggestion of a wall
between us
it's rather unpleasant listening to him
damn people to the deepest circle of
hell oh my god
aren't you curious what she does
yeah i'm picturing office space yeah
yeah yeah me too you don't build a big
picture
uh your podcast offers much better
sounds for the ears well that's good i
mean it's
it's it's a good
it's a low bar it is yes
uh don't worry about me though i'm
likely to get a job offer from an
incredible non-yeli company this week
all right congrats yeah fingers crossed
would you rather only be able to drive
at or below the speed limit except in
life or death emergencies or
always be driven by someone else and
never hit any traffic or obstacles
this is easy for me ah
it's a good question but it's easy for
me uh you know it's funny we were just
talking about the speed limit yeah was
it yesterday yesterday weird so funny we
were talking about how we used to
we live in an area with a lot of like 25
mile per hour speed limit zones and
people they just whip down these streets
i mean they [ __ ] fly
and in these big suvs they just fly down
the road and we were talking about how
when we were younger
i i we used to drive like that yeah and
the thought of driving i mean not
recklessly no no but but certainly the
idea of driving the speed limit in a 25
zone was like unheard of no i now
i'm very comfortable in most cases
unless i'm rushing i'm very comfortable
driving that speed limit me too i mean
30 maybe but i i don't mind it i've
thought about this a lot because i i
yeah i've i find myself struggling with
people you know going through stop signs
and driving like
you know driving uns unsafe
and i think it's because you sound old i
know i do but i and i and i know that
that is like a symptom of being old but
i don't a i don't think it's a bad thing
um and that's what an old person would
say
and they would say a and then they'd say
b they have to be like bullet points of
how i feel about but it's it's because i
think
um
that time you know the longer you live
the more precious time becomes and that
and and you're exposed to more people
who
die frankly sure and i think the more
aware of the danger yeah you are yes and
the fragility of life and the thought of
god being hit by some
[ __ ] little young punk in a
jeep or something daddy's jeep you know
it's like it's just careening through a
stop sign it's like
it makes me really angry and the thought
of my loved one of mine being
hurt the same way is like because of
somebody can't just
follow a rule so you would pick driving
the speed limit for sure okay i would
too but quick counterpoint yeah two
things
two counterpoints one
uh
it would be nice
i mean a reason to pick the other one it
would be nice to not have to ever deal
with traffic no that's true that's one
thing that's true so that makes this
second option kind of appealing it is
but also
the ops the word obstacles i was
i
i was confused by because if an obstacle
includes an accident oh yeah
then you'd have to you might have to
rethink your answer so if getting driven
all the time
means not only no traffic but no
obstacles you never get into an accident
then you might have to pick that you
never hit any traffic or obstacles
you're right that would technically be
enough is that an obstacle is it it it's
not preventing you it is preventing you
from going further
if it is an obstacle then i would pick
being driven because i don't want to i
want a life yeah where i'm guaranteed no
car accidents that's true
um and that's worth giving up driving
that's true but if but if it's just
traffic
and driving the speed limit i would
definitely drive the speed limit and and
you know deal with traffic once in a
while with the the other difficulty and
i i'd still pick the first one but the
other difficulty with that is that
driving these because she says at or
below the speed limit it's like yeah
i've slowed down a lot and i'm not like
but there are times it's annoying to go
55 on the highway all the time it would
it would definitely annoying it would i
definitely don't do that on the highway
but it would be worse not to be able to
drive i think
yeah yeah but road trips are so fun i
mean i love and also we talked about
this a couple weeks ago like the freedom
of driving you know just like that it's
just nice good question though it is
good thank you um keep up the quality
podcast podcastery
your best friend
stephanie oh a female person age 30. oh
stephanie oh thanks stephanie yeah
stephanie oh
um thank you that was a great letter um
and and good luck with the new job i
hope that works and non-yelli
at it for a non-yelling company
speaking of non-yelli yeah also thanks
to
jillian yes oh fine full circle you said
she was good and not yeah would you
celebrate she knew how to quiet down or
something
she knew when to be quiet that young
whippersnapper
and thanks to all of you for listening
oh we should also say that if you would
like to write a show yes you want to say
it sure what's the email address the
email is life is short at wondery.com
yeah so please write in and uh thank you
to all of our uh
sponsors both
real and imagined like um well the real
ones being but like seltzer of course
and uh you know all the the usual
suspects audible but also the louise
jersey mike's police we love it so much
i always get a number eight okay
number two who cares who cares and um
and thanks for listening
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it is co-hosted and produced by
you christian long another producer is
megan v monaco and katie v allen the
senior producer is michelle
and audio engineer sergio enriquez
executive producer marshall louis for
wandering bye
[Music]
long enough um no i'm not sure you mean
you mean
big enough to fend for themselves
well how big do you think a turtle would
have to be defend for itself
oh well one of those turtles i would say
like that
yeah where do you come up with this
stuff i don't know
like how what would that size turtle
benefit well how would they benefit from
being that size you have more muscles
muscles or a shell bigger shell
from like predators yeah like what kind
of predators snakes uh-huh
am i right yeah what else
are like raccoons sure
i've hung around you long enough to know
these things what about the big one
there's largemouth bass that they get
eaten by pass ethan yeah sometimes and
other turtle and snapping turtles oh
you know that's that big trouble i know
but what am i going to do i can't keep
them from
todd has enjoyed having them but i think
it's yes but i think i think even he is
at the end of his room
even he's like uh when are you coming to
pick him up i mean in a very nice way
you